Chúnga, đừng có một nơi đứa được vô bài cửa
và đi sẽ tử xác được vị ở kháchomsa đi vào
Mà em đi sẽ hai bà tiểu
ạ! Cà tục xú, bắt mài, bắt mài
Vì hoa, bắt mài, đúng không?
Mà truyền này, những cái em truyền hà lập đâu
Cái cư trế vụ là nó ngọt khó khăn
Cô gắng để sả hết, sợ phụ trế vụ là nó mài đâu
Sợ đến năng xong được hạn mới
Vì ở vô dợ mọi người ai cũng có xong trí tên
Mọi người ai cũng xong trí tên xong trí lòng
Vì cái lệ lợ khách thì
Nó cũng ngồi đã số đang phần bào
Vì người lào động miếng
Không động ngày thôi
Bộ
Bộ tắc là mình phút cho để xem
Nó là người ta còn người ta người ta vào người ta còn
Đi luôn người ta rất là tựa xe đi
Mà có hương người người ta
Mất xe đây người ta đi
Rất là mình